long three or zingers with the first
basket tonight for the mascot for Wesley
good defensive possession a lot of good
defensive possessions in the opening six
minutes in the game as coach sickness is
there to flush home on this by Powell
don't be surprised what the Mavericks
are up right now a missed by power cords
incas putting the ball down draws the
second defender from the pass to the
open man Justin Jackson a three pointer
Walker's got a good finish to both on
the offensive side and the defensive
side of the ball porzingis Quinn John
Hanson three got a challenger when the
guy shoots it that will just job by Kate
Beaton
defensively the long white in the game
yes sir he's stopping and popping not
thinking about it just everybody coming
down and claim scepter a few days
removed from a 30 point game in Mexico
City against Detroit and softly that cut
sterling Brown here he comes
he has it swatted both ends of the floor
porzingis from the weak side defensive
tone and three-point shooting really
good shake us then takes off and soars
and scores KP on the offensive side put
it on the deck with the left hand and
the unicorn this is kind of an out of
nowhere deal there's no like a
concentration when it comes to shooting
the ball for the map rights to curry
curry around George Hill off the window
to foul it's respect on the three-point
shooting ability opponents lately six of
the last eight wins have been by 15 plus
to the pics line and out of the timeout
lead back up to none on the Jay by
Quincy it's pure dollars against great
defensive team awesome five turnovers in
the second quarter as well
Blake clock here it's porzingis letting
it rip and it's a five-point madly
continue to move that basketball and get
those quality looks can't turn it over
against his team sounds like your pay
now Briana's but Dowell seesaws back in
front port Zynga's and the paint is as
well said all the damage done by honest
now curry all around the defense yeah
the eggs for crystalline where's ingots
quickly up delivered the pass and it's
chef curry with a chance for for what's
occurring so you know he can knock down
shots the defense overzealous Seth right
now big part of what Dallas is doing on
the offensive bit of the flow and the
power of quick rejuvenation and
apparently part of that recovery that he
spent the de panne Corey is calling for
head back beats the shot clock Drano
moving the ball with right attacking the
defense
everyone has touched it on this
possession who's going to have the
responsibility of putting up the shot is
still on right off the cut and the
reverse traffic rebound by the white
powell attack that ball was attacked
that time by the founders it was not for
the faint of heart inside that time the
truth drive seth Curry a the wind again
[Applause]
fitting stuff with a tight boat along
the face line keeps the ball in play
saves it in Dallas has it in the hands
of sent for a step-back law - yes sir
porzingis sliding through the defects
got the ball back
let's still show the replay for the
play today they should have been out of
Dallas but the massive scarred with a
fountain that he spent stuck in the
corner they the prime self out of that
problem
and porzingis a walk back we go into the
back half of the fourth quarter now the
unicorn matthews here balls at three
trying to say that is Yanis but he just
saves it right into Jalen Brunson and
good job arbrunson the ball up the board
to report to Center is a throwing
situation on the made free throw now the
free throws up a free throw Milwaukee
ball though or is it Dallas ball I'm
sorry Deb ball yeah it went out
[Applause]
Brown block by porzingis until